il était temps parce que là ça commence
à bien faire
piscine premières brasses pour les
nageurs des clayes-sous-bois les
piscines dans l'intérieur sont désormais
autorisés à rouvrir
il y avait là que cet après midi là pour
accéder au grand bassin nous avons aussi
poster des messages sur les réseaux
sociaux pour que l'information se
propage rapidement à temps nous
attendons les usagers avec impatience là
je vois je vois autour de nous que les
les gens reviennent progressivement
cela faisait huit mois que la piscine
salvador allende aux clayes-sous-bois
été fermée au public lambda
les nageurs étaient donc ravis de
retrouver le chemin des bassins
on attendait avec beaucoup d'impatience
avec les enfants on a profité de
d'accompagner les enfants club de
natation et après on enchaîne sur le
petit moment de détente habituellement
bien trois fois par semaine donc ouais
on aime bien nager donc là les problèmes
de dos donc voila c'était ça manquait
énormément avec le télétravail le dos
magath un protocole strict reste
nécessaire port du masque obligatoire
jusqu'à la douche interdiction de
prendre une douche en sortie fléchage au
sol et quasi condamné les gens viennent
avec leur leurs affaires se changent
rapidement dans les vestiaires prennent
leur douche nage et repartent dans un
autre vestiaire pour limiter les
croisements une jauge a également été
mise en place la capacité de personnes
en simultané a été réduite de 50%
ce sont donc deux cent soixante
personnes qui peuvent nager en même
temps la piscine est accessible sans
réservation est ouverte aux horaires
habituels